in the weeks before joe biden took
office a little over a year ago federal
officials met to decide how they were
going to distribute the new covid
vaccines if you'll think back you'll
remember that december of 2020 was the
deadliest month to date in the covid
pandemic more than 65 000 americans had
died that month
people were very afraid of the virus
then there was no treatment protocol for
it vaccines seemed like the only hope so
the meeting was very significant the
cdc's chief medical officer a person
called kathleen dooling unveiled her
plan to distribute the vaccines
nationally she began by acknowledging
that older americans indeed faced the
greatest risk as everyone understood
so logically if he wanted to save as
many americans as possible from dying
you would give preference the very first
shots to people over 65 that's the
obvious policy it might be the only
morally defensible policy but there was
a problem with doing that she explained
older americans were too white as
dueling put it quote racial and ethnic
minority groups are underrepresented
among adults aged 65 and older and this
meant according to dueling they could
not be allowed to get the first coveted
shots whether they needed them or not so
instead dueling recommended giving
priority to a group the government
started calling essential workers their
main qualification was not that they
were essential but they were less white
than old people so that's what the cdc
went with its panel overwhelmingly
approved kathleen dueling's
recommendation
none of this got a lot of notice at the
time but it was a major change
never in american history modern history
in any case has the federal government
made it official policy to withhold
life-saving medical treatment from
americans on the basis of their skin
color
but that's exactly what the cdc did
those most likely to die of covid had to
wait weeks until their vaccines were
approved
how many of them died in the meantime as
they waited no one kept track of those
numbers because nobody seemed to care
and because nobody cared the trend
continued
race had become a deciding factor in the
distribution of critical health care in
this country several states made it
explicit whites would go last in the
covet vaccine queue regardless of need
the state of vermont did this so did the
state of montana
and then the moment he was declared
president-elect joe biden made it
official
a concept called equity a kind of hyper
aggressive racially hostile affirmative
action would form the basis of
everything the new administration did
beginning with covid policy here's biden
before even being sworn in last year
i want to be very clear what my
priorities are
for distributing this emergency age
swiftly and equitably
our focus will be on small businesses on
main street
that aren't wealthy and well connected
that are facing real economic hardships
through no fault of their own
our priority will be black latino asian
and native american-owned small
businesses women-owned businesses
so you'll notice the assumption in that
sentence which undergirds all the
assumptions behind the administration's
equity policy and that is that non-white
means poor and non-white means less
healthy as a factual matter that's
certainly not true across the board it's
not even close to true in fact the
highest income groups in this country
are not white but they've run with it
and he made good on that promise
in its first year the bite
administration awarded billions of
dollars in coveted relief for example to
black farmers purely on the basis of
their skin color race was the only
criterion now doing that was illegal
obviously it violated all kinds of
federal laws and the federal court soon
struck it down but the white house
didn't stop they accelerated and they
applied that same standard to everything
very much including the allocation of
health care health care for all that was
the slogan for generations the new
slogan under the biden administration
was health care for favored groups
and those policies continue tonight
they're legal they're immoral and yet
they are all but ignored by the media
and by the way by republican lawmakers
several weeks ago for example the food
and drug administration released a fact
sheet on a monoclonal antibody called
sotrova map so tropomab is at this point
the only monoclonal antibody treatment
that has proven effective against the
latest variant of the chronovirus
the fda provided guidance for physicians
in all 50 states telling them how to
determine which patient should get this
treatment this critical treatment
physicians the fda explains should
consider quote race and ethnicity as
they administer treatments and so
physicians are doing that across the
country
in utah covid patients are triaged by a
scoring system that determines whether
or not they qualify for these
potentially life-saving antibody
treatments look at this chart it shows
the scoring system you'll notice that
race often counts more than physical
health
the state of utah for example gives two
points to anyone simply for not being
white you win if you're not white if you
have congestive heart failure at the
same time you get one point
so if you're a white congestive heart
failure patient that's not enough for
you
it's the same story in minnesota
minnesota awards two points to so-called
bypoc patients that means anyone who's
not white
if you have high blood pressure and
you're 60 years old
you get one point so tough luck for you
imagine if that was one of your parents
it is one of someone's parents
in new york writes aaron cebarium in a
shocking new piece for the washington
free beacon quote racial minorities are
automatically eligible for scarce covet
19 therapeutics regardless of age or
underlying conditions
it doesn't matter what kind of health
they're in all that matters is their
skin color
whites don't qualify
this is not healthcare it's punishment
it's punishment meted out on the basis
of skin color now the justification for
all of this the authorities could not be
clearer about it they've taken their
ideas directly from america's colleges
they'll tell you why they're doing this
the justification is history the united
states has mistreated racial minorities
in centuries past they say therefore
whites must suffer now so your ancestors
did bad things or people who looked like
your ancestors did bad things so now
we're withholding medicine from you
they call this equity it's not equity it
is collective punishment it's the north
korean standard it's the definition of
evil
and in case you're wondering that's
actually what it is consider this
a young haitian man could cross our
border illegally today many have
that person could show up at a clinic in
new york tomorrow for coveted treatment
and get preference over an elderly
american citizen purely because of his
appearance think about that
the haitian has not suffered from
systemic racism in america whatever that
is
he just got here but he goes to the
front of the line anyway now that's not
criticism of the haitian it's not his
fault he didn't make the rules but the
americans who did make the rules clearly
didn't make them on the basis of public
health
they made them in an effort to hurt a
specific group of americans and they're
succeeding
this is happening everywhere even in
places you would never expect it to
happen
watch as this man talks to an employee
at a texas medical facility to find out
exactly what their policies are
so i'm not gonna be able to get it today
because i don't qualify yeah what if i
what if i like
smoke and vape i heard that was uh
no
okay
but if i were black and hispanic
then i'd be able to qualify yeah okay
i'm being denied medical service because
my race is that
area so you can't get life-saving drugs
from the government of texas if you're
the wrong color
think about that
we reached out to the texas department
of health about this back in november
and they denied allocating any health
care on the basis of race but of course
they were lying
the north central texas covid19 regional
infusion center was created by the texas
department of health
last year the infusion center's website
which says it's state funded featured an
information sheet that explicitly listed
race as an eligibility factor for
getting antibody therapy that's what you
just saw there someone being denied
medical treatment because he's the wrong
color without even assessing the
relative health risks involved the
website maintained by the tarrant county
texas by the county of terrence county
in texas explains that being non-white
automatically makes you eligible for
treatments
so this is still happening on a wide
scale
the question is why are americans
putting up with this it's immoral
we're used to hearing that your kids
can't get into a certain school if
they're the wrong color or get a certain
job if they don't have the right
appearance and apparently you've
accepted that the only sin is
complaining about it that makes you a
monster
but denying health care to american
citizens because of their race
that is too much
actually it's terrifying hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else